c'est le berceau du printemps arabe
là où tout a commencé lorsque la rue
tunisienne a triomphé du dictateur ben
ali
on était dans la rue c'était calme au
début et puis c'était le cas où les
bombes lacrymogènes les balles réelles
lina ben mhenni se souvient comme si
c'était hier du 14 janvier 2011
on avait de gros grève quoi et tout le
monde donnait son avis exprimés par
rapport à la construction de la nouvelle
tunisie et d'encre mais cinq ans plus
tard l'ambiance a changé dans le pays
les assassinats politiques les attentats
terroristes se sont succédé et ont
façonné une nouvelle tunisie très
différente de celle qu'elle souhaitait
aujourd'hui malheureusement mon chien
peu triste à cause de toutes ces
barrières et les barbelés
on a cherché à la liberté et la c c'est
fermé de partout en quelque sorte blocus
très célèbre ici lina ben mhenni avoue
profiter des avancées notables en
matière de liberté d'expression dans le
pays
mais elle n'est pas d'accord avec ceux
qui présentaient tunisie comme un
exemple de réussite poste printemps
arabe
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas une guerre
civile que ce n'est pas le chaos oui
voilà la révolution c'est pour aller de
l'avant et non pas pour avoir une
régulation
on a une régression sur tous les plans
une opinion que partage en bonne partie
hamma hammami
cet opposant de gauche qui a lutté
contre bourguiba et ben ali pendant 40
ans dont une dizaine en prison et dans
la clandestinité considère que la
révolution n'est pas terminée
ce qu'on n'a pas pu réaliser jusqu'à
maintenant c'est cette révolution
économique aussi et sociales en faveur
des travailleurs en faveur de prison en
faveur des chômeurs en faveur même des
classes moyennes les motifs
d'insatisfaction de la population en
tunisie sont très nombreux l'économie
est au point mort le taux de chômage
atteint les 15% et dépasse même les 30 %
chez les jeunes diplômés
quant à la corruption elle l a augmenté
si on y ajoute les frustrations
mohamed kamel jendoubi les partages en
bonne partie même s'il est aujourd'hui
ministre du projet il est vrai que les
gouvernements qui se sont succédé depuis
2011 était mal préparée à l'exercice du
pouvoir
on est on a perdu beaucoup de temps ça
c'est clair mais peut-être c'est comme
ça qu'il faut voir les choses
l'apprentissage ne se fait pas par la
théorie se ferait par la pratique et
plus encore par les échecs que par les
victoires
cinq ans après la révolution de jasmin
la nouvelle tunisie demeure un
gigantesque chantier qui laisse donc
forcément à tous un goût d'inachevé mais
où les optimistes peuvent se dire que
tout est encore possible
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
tunis